[Applause]
a simple case of Eastern Michigan having
no idea who they're guarding Imani dates
for three welcome back
they can still turn out in a very good
way even though the struggles have been
there Armani Bates a guy that he's been
through a lot in terms of being a
superstar in a social media age and how
about that shot over the top
we've got a good one here tonight at
Little Caesars arena in Detroit Lovejoy
On The Run no but look at the following
Bates now 14 points
I will say about Imani Bates as he's
taking shots from within the offense now
this is a heat check right here
he's putting on a show
Michigan back into the lead and now date
scores to give it Eastern the lead back
in the foul
yeah
what a bizarre ending meets for three
yes with 9.3 not so fast
tonight
[Applause]
Bates the Deep three as he gets that to
fall
if you can't get into your offense or if
you can't even get the ball pass half
court then that is helping Eastern
Michigan
well Jihad wanted it in the post instead
Bates said I'm gonna take it myself
pulls up from three and hits
Brown the turnaround no good the rebound
for Amani Bates
Bates pulls up a deep three got it
now it's just Bozeman's for donk on him
[Applause]
tough shot unbelievable Amani Bates
Bates missed his shot now we got a slow
PG player getting up at Sprint Mills so
it's a five on four advantage here for
Eastern for the time being Bates takes
it right to the rack perhaps his first
field goal those would close within two
a couple times
there's Bates
the defense here by Mills Bates puts it
up wow what a shot by Imani